what's up everybody we are back with
megan fox give it up
the month of may means a lot of great
things flowers are in bloom
summer is around the corner uh school is
almost out for your kids all your moms
and daddy's out there
and each year we take memorial day to
honor those who have given their lives
serving in our military this is
something very important to megan which
is why she's partnered with army combat
veteran
colin wayne so colin is joining us now
thank you for joining us
and thank you so much for your service
it seems so silly and such a little
thing
to say for you giving so much but but
thank you
we really do appreciate it and i'm
curious how you two even met and how
this all happened
you reached out to me yeah reached out
from far over there
um uh about the products and and the
business that you have and so
i i collaborated with him once before um
i have veterans in my family my uncles
are
all vets um but you you should tell more
i'm assuming
it probably has something to do with the
fact that like the transformers movies
especially
michael especially is very like um pro
military very supportive of the military
and those movies like
reached out and like featured a lot of
military and were very inclusive in that
way so i imagine like
that might be where the dog i have so i
have a small i might have a small voice
in that community or like be able to
help him and also
you're like a big huge star that people
pay attention to that's maybe one too
i'll say that for you but how did you
how did you end up hooking up
what we wanted to partner with somebody
you you mentioned a small voice but your
voice is magnified it's it's massive
and um we know that that you know you
went overseas
um to korea and visited the troops
you know i did three tours um egypt iraq
and afghanistan and so
when we were looking for somebody to
kind of spread the message and the
awareness of what memorial day even is
to begin with because it's been lost in
this nation of the true meaning
it was a clear understanding that this
could be a great fit and it has been
this is our second year doing it and
it's it's been an honor i know last year
we donated
over two and a half million dollars in
products wow
that's amazing yeah so why i have to ask
you
because i was asking anybody that served
their country what drew you to serving
our country
so like a lot of people i grew up in a
split home
uh just like you kelly and um my my mom
primarily raised me
and i i didn't have a difficult
childhood but
i had an older brother that i looked up
to as a father figure
he joined the military at 17.
and i ended up getting kicked out of my
mom's house i wasn't a bad kin but
i was stubborn by nature and i just
wouldn't listen to her so i dropped out
of high school at 16 joined the military
at 17 after getting emancipated
and went as a military police officer
and made staff sergeant in six years
i was one of the youngest staff
sergeants and in the army without being
special forces and
actually volunteered for all three of my
tours so
egypt iraq and afghanistan wow
um well something happened on your last
tour what was it
so i remember it like it was yesterday
which ironically
was just a few days ago nine years ago i
was in afghanistan
in the paktika province which is right
on the pakistan border
and a rock had impacted about three and
a half feet from me
and through the grace of god i survived
shrapnel went all the way through my leg
i remember i blacked out i regained
consciousness
and um it was i couldn't see my hand in
front of my face
um i could i was yelling for a medic but
nobody was coming and it felt like
eternity
but really it was only a few minutes i
remember
it was just like a movie set but it was
true two black hawks came in
picked me up i was the only casualty
they flew me to another base
and i ended up sustaining
shrapnel to both arms piece went all the
way through my leg and almost had to
have it amputated
uh treat it for traumatic brain injury
and then
l1 through l3 nerve damage in my back so
i had to have a
lumbar block fusion surgery wow so i
mean how do you
not only recover from that physically
but like emotionally and mentally
so ironically i started working out in
2009
uh right before i started to go to iraq
for my second tour and um i
that was the gym was my my real focal
point it helped me
that mind-body connection ironically
uh i got blown up in a gym on my base
that i thought was a safe harbor
um but the gym helped me cope with a lot
of things mentally and then it
it and i say ironic several times
because i pivoted
from the military into becoming a
fitness model
and that setback was a setup for my
future wow
what i need to write that down for
myself
so you've partnered um to do something
special for memorial day so what is it
so uh this year i'm honored for our
second annual
uh soldier memorial give back last year
we had an incredible response and we had
the privilege to
donate over two and a half million
dollars worth of product and
this year we we planned to do the same
with a minimum
of a million dollars any anytime i put
my name behind something i want it to be
a hundred percent
for me it's important that memorial day
is a day to honor not me as a veteran
but to those that paid the ultimate
sacrifice
nine years ago that could have been me
that that got killed and
fortunately i'm i'm here to be a voice
for the voiceless
yeah i'm here to be a voice for the
family members
that lost their loved ones to their sons
their daughters
their husbands you know their moms their
dads
it's important to me as a as an
entrepreneur as a veteran
to be a hands extended and to be a voice
for those that simply do not have a
voice
anymore kenny well two questions so can
you tell us about your company
one and then two how can people help
what is
if people are really wanting to help how
what can they do
so 2016 i founded a company redline
steel
and we manufacture wall art decor
this the piece that we're actually
donating for free
is a really beautiful nine
inch steel sign that we're literally
just giving away for free
um the the meaning behind it is
those that fallen comrades in in active
line of service
um from iraq to afghanistan this soldier
memorial represents them
and so this is a remembrance piece
nowadays
it's memorial day is known for companies
monetizing you you you sales social
media across the board
you look at car sales or buy this
mattress memorial day sale
this is the opposite we want to put
people over profit
we want to truly spread the message
and hopefully have a third annual and
fourth annual
memorial day give back it's not about
just me as a veteran
it's not about um anything other than
uh the family members that lost their
loved ones
um i agree with you i think people have
lost sight of that well thank you so
much
for your service once again and thank
you all for teaming up this is really
cool
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever